i would love to ask you some rapid fire
questions are you guys ready
okay
here we go dylan song you can't stop
listening to right now
uh
funny girl by father john misty
oh my god i love father john misty so
much great okay mason what was the last
lie you told
uh
that i
enjoyed the dinner that my friend made
me oh geez
jasmine would you where would you go if
you could go anywhere in the world i
know you love travel
i'd love to go to egypt i would love to
go to egypt great answer okay
mikey what go to binge food right now
popcorn
okay sonia
i need a makeup trend you're obsessed
with oh the makeup i'm wearing right now
it's like a cut crease situation yes i
see a cut crease oh you're so hot i love
it okay dylan you're going to order ice
cream what flavor are you picking
something with cookie dough
i i say just grab that cookie dough and
just eat it right out of the tube mason
first date drinks or
art class
oh an art class i want to see if we're
good at art i'm compatible in that way
that's cute
very nice okay jasmine you're stranded
on an island what's the one thing you're
taking
boombox i need water i mean i need music
i was in my head going water or a
boombop so a boombox made of water
okay mikey um do you believe in love at
first sight yes or no
yes of course okay and sonia um if you
have to pick one show to recommend
people to watch right now what would it
be
yellow jackets because josslyn's in it i
agree
i love you
and as a last question to each one of
you it's the same one and it's the one i
ended with nev courtney and david so if
you'll do me the honor of bringing it
full circle
um i'm going to start with you dylan
what is the scariest thing about you
whoa
um
i feel like embarrassed about how i look
in like shorts
[Laughter]
mason what's the scariest thing about
you
uh i'm incredibly competitive when it
comes to dumb things like uh board games
okay jasmine what's the scariest thing
about you
i think the scariest thing about me is
who i become when i'm hungry i will snap
on a dime i'll be so happy cheerful
sweet and then they're like oh no we
brought you the wrong order and i
immediately start crying
you get hangry mikey what's the scariest
thing about you
well i'm a very messy person
uh a few people on the cast know this
about me you're messy too
yeah i'm trying to improve that
uh yeah it's it's really bad i even
um
before my hair and makeup people came i
had a bunch of dishes in the sink and so
i just like put a towel over it like i'm
just gonna
ignore that like it's not there so
maybe it's my i don't know my messiness
okay sonia what's the scariest thing
about you
oh oh i
i sleep talk a lot and i sleep sing like
i sing in my sleep
and
twice a year i feel like yeah once or
twice a year i also sleepwalk and do all
sorts of weird things and you'll just
find me in the kitchen in the middle of
the night
doing i don't know what um
so i feel like it's terrifying if you
have a sleepover with me
and that happens yeah okay i was
wondering in honor of scream and i had
to like scream to get the film of e.t so
i sort of like have this love for
screams
because it kind of changed my life a
scream um i wouldn't be who i was if i
didn't get et and they really had an
audition for me where i had to scream so
um i was wondering if both of all of us
could take our phones um starting with
dylan and go down the line and each of
you could record yourself doing a scream
uh my girlfriend is asleep so i might
scare them by the way you could do a
scream that is like the i can't scream
every there's no rules it's whatever
scream you interpret
all right watch this
perfect
perfect
okay
mason give it to me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i love i love the cloth afterwards
jasmine let her rip
[Music]
brilliant
mikey my love
go for it
[Music]
and last but not least sonia
that was a high-pitched one all right
i'm gonna join you guys in solidarity
here we go three two one
oh good thank you dylan mason jasmine
mikey and sonia scream is out in
theaters january 14th we'll all be there
for it
[Music]